après des mois sur pause toronto
commence à redevenir une ville en
ébullition
mais avec ce retour à la normale via le
constat que le paysage du centre-ville a
changé beaucoup de petits commerces
n'ont pas survécu et ont été remplacés
par de nouveaux joueurs les magasins de
cannabis qui ont poussé comme des
champignons pendant le confinement entre
spectateurs et bathurst et y en a une
dizaine déjà le quartier de chama amrani
a accueilli beaucoup de ces nouvelles
boutiques et a perdu toutes sortes de
commerces indépendants magasin de tapis
magasins des meubles d'occasion
bars etc n'importe il remplace tout quoi
le restaurateur qui est établi sur la
rue queen ouest depuis vingt ans déplore
ce changement est décrit même phénomène
d'embourgeoisement et a pas mal d'argent
derrière ça donc il peut rester avec les
portes ouvertes même sont pas très
occupé chavez hamlin est pas seule à
s'inquiéter du nombre grandissant de
commerce de cannabis à toronto
à quelques mètres de son restaurant le
propriétaire de magasin de vêtements
fait le même constat
c'est difficile ça rend la rue un peu
ennuyeuse lâche d'entrepreneurs au
québec on compte un grand total de
soixante dix huit succursales de la saq
décès à toronto seulement ou la vente de
cannabis se relève entièrement du privé
il y a près de 200 boutiques et la
tendance est nettement accéléré dans la
dernière année en 2021 cent soixante
trois permis ont déjà été octroyés
je magasine cannabis fait partie de
sucre une récemment ouvert leurs portes
le groupe détient six magasins au total
et va en ouvrir quatre autres à toronto
cette année
les affaires vont assez bien firme la
pdg du groupe supérette mais même les
représentants de l'industrie admettent
que la prolifération de magasin peut
paraître choquant est que le temps dira
quels joueurs parviendront à survivre
cette conseillère municipale ne pense
pas que la demande pour des produits
cannabis justifie l'offre excessive
surtout dans le centre-ville de toronto
où les loyers peuvent facilement coûter
des dizaines de milliers de dollars par
mois
devant l'ampleur du phénomène qui si
nous on t'aime demande à la province
d'intervenir et de jolies l'octroi de
permis
de son côté le gouvernement provincial
dit ne pas avoir l'intention d'apporter
de changements à son modèle de
distribution de permis pour ceux qui
voudraient voir moins de magasins de
cannabis en ontario il ne reste donc
qu'à espérer un changement de cap du
gouvernement ou que la loi du marché
finesse par éliminer les commerces moins
compétitifs ici à semaine n'était radio
canada toronto